hey mr. wonderful here and this is
another episode of ask mr. wonderful
now what I like about this is
no-holds-barred you ask me any question
you want and I give you the answers you
ask I answer now bring them on
[Music]
hi mr. wonderful this is mica from
Jersey so I recently started my own
company and I just want to know when do
you know when to start hiring employees
right now I have a few clients at hand
and I just want to know when is the best
possible chance like monetary why is to
start hiring my first few employees or
should I continue doing things on by
myself and my partner Mike a great
question let me tell you about having
employees the only reason you had
employees is sales is growing you don't
add employees unless revenues increasing
because you can't afford them if you
have sales growth then you have to start
thinking about getting support people so
your customer service level stays in the
top quartile that's when you hire people
you're always keeping your eye on how do
I service my customers how do I make
sure my employees are happy how to make
sure my investors are happy those are
your three constituencies but number one
is you've got to have happy customers
and the reason you bring on the risk of
that extra overhead is you need
employees to do that so no hiring
anybody until your sales go up every
time you double your sales you should
add a couple of people to do customer
service and support in all areas of the
business whether it's accounting whether
it's you know what you do online to
support them whether it's marketing with
its sales those people are supporting
customers at the end of the day that's
how it works no hiring anybody so sales
go up
hi mr. wonderful my name is Luis I am
from Mexico and I've been following you
for the past four years I would like to
ask you because you have said in the
past that you have been to every beach
on earth I want to know if that's even
true and how did you manage to
accomplish such a difficult goal how did
you do that it's one of the benefits of
traveling every beach on earth as I met
all the locals tried all the local foods
and that's when I became chef wonderful
because I'm a fantastic chef and I
recreated all those dishes with my
certain Jeunesse a qua that I added
myself so my dishes all come from my
journeys to all these countries and all
these beaches and now chef wonderful is
born
I can read hi this is a middle from
India actually I wanted to ask you that
how can I overcome my self-doubt and
other people's opinions especially my
close ones like my family and how can I
grow my business to run actually
Swapnil fantastic question you know
every entrepreneur has self-doubt it's
just that you don't want to show it to
the outside world people want to follow
somebody that knows where they're going
but you have to be able to deal with
your insecurities you can't let your
family tell you you don't know what
you're doing not when you have a burning
desire to be an entrepreneur the key to
success though is to find somebody that
I've münster skills if you're great in
one area find someone who's better in
another that you're weakened that's how
you can really reduce your self-doubt
and make your outcomes much better
because you're reducing your risk by
getting a partner in the business but
don't let someone tell you can't do it
that's just crap particularly your
family
many people are jealous about
entrepreneurs they want to try it but
they don't have the guts to do it even
within a family that happens doesn't
mean you don't love them it's just
you're not listening to them when they
give you all that naysayer stuff stay
focused on the goal and deal with your
insecurities everybody has them ready
we're sitting on the set of Shark Tank
Season eleven being taped right now all
of this money is mine when I make an
investment it's my personal cash that's
why I care about it so much I care about
these deals because it's my cash
hi Kevin
let's talk about brandy I saw you alive
at the NAC tour in Atlanta in July one
of the things you mentioned was branding
is a new cost to consider if damaged it
could cost billions of dollars
how could senior executives who is at
the pinnacle in their career effectively
invest in their personal branding be an
amazing question personal branding is
really interesting one of the reasons
I'm doing this YouTube channel is to
talk to people directly to see what I'm
really like when I'm outside of the
shark tank you know I'm not wearing a
suit right now I'm just being honest
with you about the decisions I have to
make every day like everybody else does
I'm an ordinary person like anybody else
that focuses on the task I got to get
done during the day but you right you
raised a really interesting question
personal branding is about integrity and
honesty because people smell [ __ ]
from a mile away these days and so
you've got to be honest with people even
when it's hard to be honest it's
important to be honest because your
reputation you know is very very long
time to build and you can lose it just
like that if people feel you're being
dishonest
hey mr. wonderful my question for today
is I'm 20 years old and I don't know
what to put my main focus and attention
to right now I'm going to college and
I'm looking to start up ecommerce
business like drop shipping and things
like that or creating YouTube some sort
of thing to create passive income but I
don't know if I should put most of my
focus on that or school or continuing
working I really don't know
hey Rolla let me give you some advice a
little bit of focus here the two things
I like to do simultaneously and I always
did is I worked while I went to school I
picked a discipline that I thought would
advance my opportunities as an
entrepreneur or just in getting me more
money in an any job and while I worked
at night I was often a waiter or a sling
a bar or some beer at bars and anything
I could do to make money I often worked
wet
as a bartender I did everything when I
was in school but I focused on
disciplines that I thought I could turn
into something later so I did both and I
think maybe that's something you want to
think about why just only have one when
you're young you lots of energy you only
need five or six hours of sleep spend
the rest of time learning and working
cash and knowledge they go hand in hand
good luck
I'm hi Kevin away I was wondering it's
all give you a little background
knowledge first and 2016 you did like an
interview on CNN business the YouTube
channel
dirty news and I was wondering so back
then I saw in 2016 when I was 11 years
old and I watched every single episode
of shark tank and you were talking about
your dyslexia and at that time I was in
fifth grade and I was still inverting
all my letters and numbers so um could
you talk more about how you kind of like
became super successful but you also had
like a disability at the same time
because it really means a lot to me
thank you so much biggest fan thank you
actually thank you thank you hey June
great question sounds like you have a
little dyslexia too and it comes in
various forms and everybody's different
with it
I was really falling behind at your age
and reading and math because of dyslexia
and I found this wonderful woman named
Marjorie garlic and she had a she had a
partner named Sam Rabinovich and they
brought me into a class I think 16 and
19 of us all had dyslexia and they
taught us that dyslexia is a superpower
because I could read a book upside down
in a mirror which is a strange thing one
of the attributes of dyslexia you never
know and that's one of the reasons I was
inverting my letters too but she said
look one of the biggest problems with
dyslexia and had overcome it is that
don't let it eat away at your
self-confidence go back into that
classroom where people are giving you a
hard time and say look I'm actually a
superpower I can do things you can't do
I can read this book upside down in
mirror you can't and the kids in my
classroom whoa how'd you get that
superpower I said well it's just one of
the superpowers I have it's called
dyslexia but I don't use it against you
I'm just using advanced myself and it
was a way of just getting into the self
confidence of getting around the problem
of having to learn with that so if I had
to read with a mirror I did but it got
me through math and reading scores and
you'd be surprised to learn Daymond John
who I work with on Shark Tank who's been
wildly successful he has dyslexia the
guy that started JetBlue airlines he had
dyslexia this is not something that's
going to hold you back in fact it can
even be a powerful ally to give you
self-confidence in business so I wish
you the best
don't let it ever hold you back it
doesn't have to there's lots of examples
of us that are in this special
superhuman club that we use to our
advantage
[Music]